if anyone spots william butcher or any
of his known associates marvin mill
q campbell or this man please call
1-888-0-5
homeland started off uh wanting
more basically you know he's the world's
number one superhero but
uh similar to the actor that wants to be
a producer he believed that his
he could expand his role within vort and
wanted to do more
and of course his lovely um sexy
mummy figure uh madeleine stillwell was
standing in his way and preventing him
from
from doing what he believed he could do
um so there was a bit of a bit of a
striking out and a bit of a rebellious
teenager
vibe to what homeland was doing in
season one creating
uh creating soup terrorists and in the
end it culminated with the removal
of uh madeleine stillwell because
she violated their trust and um
so that was his big you know coming out
into the world his is
uh stamping stamping his foot
and um making his mark so season two
is about picking up where he left off
and having to deal with
um the aftermath basically of taking all
those overt actions
and as he learns very quickly
with the introduction of some rather
special new characters
um life can be a lot more complex
when you haven't got your lovely handler
slash
mummy figure around to to
um to uh buffer things
you know so he's he's basically he's got
a direct line with edgar which
is very challenging you know homelander
is a
uh like many of the superheroes on the
show
they really emerged from this you know
thought game
of if that type archetype of hero with
that those powers really existed in the
real world and we're a real human being
like how would they behave and how would
they act and
for homelander uh
he would it was it was obvious to us
that he would become a sociopath
um because you just you can't be
that different than every other human
being that much better
than every other human being around you
without
starting to think that humanity is
somehow lesser and distasteful
um but by the same respect uh
he is human uh he just doesn't
he finds that part of him weak and and
hateful
because he just can't accept the fact
that he has
human vulnerable needs that's just
something he can't live with
when they're in actual combat whom
exactly do your heroes report to
same person as always me i had an idea
that this corporate human being was very
different than anyone i ever played
before
that and i i had to start with being
calm and being at ease
but had to also encompass
his intelligence so
when i started to think about his
intelligence
well how much does he know and that was
very important for me
to decide that he knows everything
we have a very powerful beginning
as homelander burst into stan edgar's
office
um and you know wants to
be angry and have a basically a shouting
confrontation on why he hasn't been
uh he was not consulted
on the hiring of stormfront and stan's a
little taken aback
and so the decision i had to make was do
i
match his intensity
in a uh in an arrogant
business-like way or should i look at
him and go oh
oh wait a minute oh i didn't i didn't
know you wanted to be informed
right so he he he turns the tables
and then it starts to educate homelander
on what the company is
and educate him and allow him
to hear it from stan's mouth of what
your job is and what your duty is and
you know it infuriates homelander i love
working with anthony starr
we have a really very wonderful rhythm
we all we need to do is just connect
and do the lines and rehearse and figure
out where we're going and then the
dynamics certainly come
it was really a wonderful scene to do
because it solidified
my feeling at who stan really is
and without giving away who he is
and to me that's important because he's
representative of the big business
that we have in our america
today the big business is running things
i mean that's and if we don't see that
then we're blind we are famous now
don't you worry
daddy's home billy butcher for season
two
um is is quite different than billy
butcher of season one
at the end of season one we come to
learn that his wife
becka butcher is indeed alive and not
only is she alive but she has a
soup son to homelander that obviously is
a bit of a huge game changer so how that
affects billy psyche going forward to
season two
and particularly for the first few
episodes is that
you know it really changes uh
billy's uh lens and his goals shift
from taking down vault which is still
you know a priority for him but his main
priority now is to reunite with his wife
to find his wife to rescue her and you
know
mentally he is i think uh
he's he's vulnerable uh it's a desperate
butcher you know we haven't seen those
sides of him before
uh you know desperate vulnerable and and
and dangerous butcher needs the
help of the the boys in order to
uh to find becca but obviously you know
butcher betrayed the boys at the end of
season one by not going to rescue them
uh so there's a lot of internal conflict
uh
that needs to be resolved before they
can even move forward on that
billy is an amazingly drawn character in
the books
i have to say we borrowed quite a lot
from the books of this
character who is really getting burnt
alive
by his own anger as we started
modernizing it really looking at it he
kind of became for us
this really interesting exploration of
toxic masculinity
um he he really presents as
the the hero of
a lot of stories that you've seen before
that kind of like
lone wolf you know character who's
you know mourning the dead wife and
fighting his way through a brutal world
um but then we sort of
analyzed him the deeper into the season
to reveal
how [ __ ] up he is and how [ __ ] up
you would have to be to create that
that image and how ultimately
destructive and toxic
it is holy [ __ ] your eyes are really
[ __ ] blue up close
you are fun stormfront is
is uh really smart
and um she's super social media savvy
she can
she she really understands all the
things that i
as a person does not like you know i
just read an article about tick tock
houses and i was like
what i i barely understand what tick
tock is let alone a house
she's very savvy about all that and and
able to
um sort of both use and
and manipulate those people
um for her own stardom and her her own
um
agenda she's definitely not what she
seems
um and uh she definitely has a dark side
uh that rivals homelanders um
i think she's probably even scarier
simply because
uh she has she has a big agenda
where his agenda sort of surrounds
himself from homelanders perspective
stormfront
is the thorn and the poor man she's just
the unavoidable
uh little pain that that he doesn't know
how to get rid of and
especially because she's supported by
the corporation you know that's the
problem with her
she can't just be removed um have to
actually deal with corporate when it
comes to her because there's you know
there's a lot
at play when it comes to that character
so she is
uh she's a an obstacle and a challenge
that
throughout season two homelander will
have to and shall overcome
stormfront you know she was a character
from the books was a male
in the books you know we gender flipped
her
um for a couple reasons um one is
again we were playing this game of
making sure that every character faces
their worst nightmare this season
and for homelander that would be a woman
who wasn't afraid of him
and was stealing his spotlight that's
the worst single thing that could happen
to that guy
um and so she comes in
and she immediately knocks him on his
ass um
and that's part of it and then another
part of it is you know without giving
away too much she's not who she appears
to be
and um she has some pretty hateful ideas
and that character did in the comics as
well but i would say
what's different about today is a lot of
people
who have really hateful notions really
wrapped themselves in a pretty
attractive social media
package you know they come off as like
disruptors who just want to
be free thinkers but then you ask them
what their free thoughts are and it's
the same hateful [ __ ]
that that people have been talking about
for thousands of years
um and so we wanted to reflect that
[Music]
psyche going into season two has a lot
to do with him
surpassing that breaking point uh in
season one like his his physical
breaking point
it's a it's a lot for him to kind of
work through
mentally and he is a he's like a finger
pointer you know what i mean is
anyone else to blame but me is kind of
like where his mindset has always been
and still
is um to be honest with you he's very
dependent on his
physical abilities to maintain his life
his status
and anything that comes in the way of
that he's we've seen in season one
the lengths that he'll go to to maintain
his status so
going into season two it's you know he
he just wants to
get back to where he fell from a train
came from again playing the exercise of
of what if they were really that hero
with that power was real
and really where we landed quickly was
like well you would be like a
professional athlete
you're a performance-based hero like
superman gets to be superman
his whole life a train you know or or
the flash
they're only that as long as they're the
fastest man once they're second or
third then [ __ ] it open a car dealership
you're out
so the idea that there were other
speedsters that are gunning for his
position
made him a really stressful professional
athlete
which is why he was you know shooting up
some extra v on the side so
we we landed on the lance armstrong
story for him
easy on the religious persecution okay
new girl
starlight maybe one day you can welcome
me back into the seven
and i know my road is long and hard so
end of season one he's he's
become completely unraveled and had the
rug pulled out from under him as far as
you know is his whole identity he's out
of seven he's been banished to ohio and
then he
he starts to realize at the very end
obviously he's one that he that it's for
real that he doesn't really know if he's
ever gonna make it back
and so uh and then season one we kind of
pick him up around the same time
and he's had a couple you know one too
many lava flows
and um you know he sort of hit rock
bottom in his personal life
and and everything else and sort of
having to face who the guy is in the
mirror
and uh you know anyone that would kind
of come out and give him a helping hand
he sort of
jumps at that first offer and you know
gets on
on a on a train of a different
philosophy of life
and and and rolls with that and anything
you can do to try and get back into into
the seven is sort of
where he's at so deep comes from
similarly
of like how would you really feel if you
had the dumbest [ __ ] power
he's only useful for water-based crime
and how insecure you would be
and therefore you would take out that
insecurity on other people like he does
to starlight because he has so much
self-hatred um
and he has such a poor vision of himself
the deep is uh just a
giant question mark i'm not even sure
why he's in the seven because he just
talks to fish and he's an idiot
are you serious there is
no [ __ ] way
you're coming back you take um starlight
in the beginning of season one
and you find someone who just earnestly
wants to make the world a better place
and save the world one crime at a time
her dream of being in the seven
is granted and then she gets inducted
into the world of the seven
through a really horrific and
traumatizing and scarring way you know
she's sexually abused by the deep
and that moment really
sets her off on a journey that she never
anticipated
and is totally the antithesis of what
she expected of that world but it's a
really quick
moment of um realization for her in
terms of what she's gotten herself into
and so the rest of the season is really
her trying to stick to her initial
objective
of making the world a better place and
being a hero and simultaneously she's
met huey her
who is her one source of levity and
lightness and joy in this dark world she
falls in love with him
ultimately learns that he has been lying
to her
and kind of using her and she finds out
that her mom has been lying to her
about you know not being born with
superpowers and has kind of
also been using her her entire life and
so
she ends up season one being totally
shattered and she's going into season
two with
a wall that is thick she is not letting
anyone in but she still wants to make
the world a better place so
that requires her to do so in a totally
different
manner of season one and she becomes
sort of an undercover
officer working at bot and playing the
game and
um putting on a facade and having to put
aside her heartbreak
and residual feelings for huey to work
with him to
um continue on uh
track for her mission starlight was
also a really well designed character
from the books um so we didn't have to
do too too much
but um we mostly just muscled up her
story i think in
in the book she's a supporting character
and we really wanted her to be one of
the leads because
frankly for the simple reason of just
truly likable characters in this world
are really thin on the ground i mean
there's there's huey and starlight
so what's your big plan you love it
i won't love it i never love it never
[ __ ] love it
no the psyche of huey campbell uh
going into season two initially he's
motivated by
revenge and he wants to take a train
down and he's recruited by this guy
named
billy butcher who uh will kind of
do anything to uh to get his own revenge
against the supes
um along the way he meets annie aka
starlight uh
and they form this bond that lets him
know
okay not all superheroes are bad people
some of them are actually very good very
altruistic people and
he starts to genuinely fall for her but
butcher is kind of manipulating kiwi to
use her uh in terms of getting more
information on the seven
um and then eventually he just has to
come clean
and say that he's been lying to her and
basically using her for
the entirety of the first season and it
does not go well
um and uh by the end of season one
butcher essentially completely abandons
the boys
uh huey feels immensely immensely
betrayed but he's able to
rescue the rest of a team from the
clutches of a bot prison
and uh him and starlight have left on
uneasy terms she lets him go she doesn't
arrest him
uh but they're not gonna be romantically
involved at least for
a good while the thing i'm really
interested in is this is this idea that
it's very very easy to be cynical and to
write cynical
and to write like cool but it's really
really hard to write
earnest and hopeful and people always
come off as idiots or naive
and i think that's sad and
so i wanted to try to create
[Music]
like a genuinely optimistic hopeful
character
who doesn't lose that part of her um or
if she does lose it and she's in danger
of losing it in season two like
she finds it and and and doesn't give up
her ideals she has that
really one of her opening lines is why
did hopefully naive become the same
thing
and and and so the the goal with her
is you know we just wanted a character
who represented light
um but didn't mean they were weak or
stupid to do it
we see kimiko building trust
with certain members of the boys well
actually
everyone except for billy butcher you
know uh
french led by frenchie uh healy and
mother's milk they both come
and rescue me um it's a very heroic
moment for mother's milk
carrying me out of there and um you know
huey busting his retainers out
in order to save me so there's a lot of
trust and
um there's a bond that's created
beginning season two we see kimiko
trying to communicate
with the boys and that comes from like a
place of
wanting to wanting to assimilate wanting
to
truly become a part of a group and to
really become
a family um and so throughout the season
you see her evolve in terms of her
communication
and we see her become more and more
humanized
i think kimiko her root
her her purpose usually is
uh coming from a need to survive it's
about survival
and we see a sneak peek of it at the end
of season one where she
is looking at herself in the mirror and
she's painting her nails and
she can she starts to realize that uh
being this feral creature that isn't
really for her
she that's not a life that she chose it
was given to her um
in a very traumatic dramatic way and
she wants to become this woman and she
wants to
pave her own path
of course we're in we blow it up
i think that in the first season we find
a lost uh frenchie making
any mistake possible with uh
one um one great mistake
which is uh finding kamiko and releasing
her
uh to the world and then
finding out that he has to uh deal with
himself
uh because she's kind of uh
a mirror to him and his world that he's
been running away from they're both
really really traumatized and really um
lost souls
he brings her into the family that
is being ripped apart with the end of
the season
with their father butcher leaving them
uh
alone and they're kind of lost hiding
with french's friends
um we're just trying to survive
from the corrupt soups and
definitely season two um
opens up so many pandora boxes for uh
both frenchy and kamiko cemente sam
simon timmy um
in the same time but with different
directions so many twists and turns with
this two
uh this season i think what's beautiful
about the relationship
is that it's not completely romantic uh
it's pretty open-ended at this point um
season two has a a couple
different things along the way
which i will not reveal but um kimiko
and frenchie they share a
similar history of trauma
of uh regretting certain
aspects of their life uh life not
happening the way that they wanted it to
and that's sort of what draws them to
one another and kimiko has
so much to learn from frenchie
because even though they have this
shared history he doesn't
he has not become a hardened shell like
she has
um she sees that frenchies
how fun she's living his own life is a
way that
she can also live life it's a choice and
up till now i think other people have
uh have have forced her into
um living life a certain way and meeting
him has opened her eyes up to the
possibilities of what could be
[Music]
you know in terms of deciding like what
to keep from the books and what not to
um it's a really stressful process it's
like the most nerve-wracking game of
jenga
ever because you might be the guy who
ruins the thing you love for the world
that's like a
really shitty position to be in um
so you know i i try to attack it
with equal parts reverence and
irreverence i would say because
look it's ultimately a different medium
and it's a it's a serialized streaming
show versus
what is a fairly episodic book um
so if you tried to translate one to one
it would really suck
it's about finding the things and the
elements in the books
that i just really spark to and respond
to and love
and and try to almost remix them
um into where they might fit in
in my version of the story and you know
and i hear
all the time from people who say like
hey screw you man the books are better
and and my response is like yo i love
the books too
like they're awesome read the books like
i read the books i love the books i'm
like
this thing is not the books this is a
different thing
that is my inspir my version of being
inspired by the books
so it's a totally different animal so
just take it on its own
own terms as its own thing we just need
to keep our [ __ ] together
we have a lot of fun like we laugh a lot
and we play practical jokes on each
other
and i i think that there's sort of you
know in the doing
of that you know we find it it's sort of
it's relaxing um but there's also this
kind of uh
mercurial mischievous sort of
sort of uh uh ethos that
that comes forward and you know i think
that really helps
you know you always want to try and stay
in that like playful font spontaneous
mode so i do try and like
you know i i i'm i'm shooting the [ __ ]
with people on set
turning the music up in my trailer and
just trying to you know not
not be too still and and all sudden you
gotta gotta be on so i do try and just i
try to have fun you know and this is
probably the most fun i've ever had
on really any set and um i try and you
know keep in that zone
i mean i i had sushi the other night i
felt really bad i i did but
that's that's the extent of my uh
interaction with marine life these days
is sushi at home
what a dark twist yeah yeah yeah exactly
something that always helps me in any
project i do is music and i
build a playlist uh based off of each
character and like
huey's there was a huey season one
playlist and a huey season two
uh there's some beach boys there's some
uh
the troggs we got jackson brown we got
of course billy joel
we got uh labie ziffer billy joel again
uh hame spoon a lot of fun uh
a lot of fun things that just kind of on
your drive to work really get you
in the headspace i definitely stretch
before there's a lot of stunt work
involved with her scenes and
i uh you know a lot of crawling on the
floor
um so i stretched before and then i make
sure
that i do not laugh at any of
frenchie's jokes first season we got we
all of us got
chairs from uh carl then les
bought himself this cow mother's milk
and put it on the chair
so uh let's just say he was wondering
where this beautiful cow was the entire
first season
what i do on set to kind of get into my
character
is very similar to what carl answered
you know we
we have a tremendous amount of fun we
played jokes on each other constantly
it's just the show just
you know you find yourself being in
situations that
you know uh you've never been in before
and you never expect to be in on any
show i
remember um lazz and i were on set
with jack quaid and we're shooting a
scene where jack
is meeting my dog tara
and tara has the propensity to hump
anything and everything in sight and
they actually cast this dog who
could perform the said task
at hand and so jack's sort of on set and
he's bonding with the animal
and uh and laz and i were on set a
little bit before jack
and and so we're a little bit more up
with the place and jet comes on set
and he sees this stuffed pig that uh
is the dog and so he picks it up and
he's like going hey bentley hey bentley
you know come here come he's playing
with him and he's you know playing with
the pig and
snuggling it up and the trainer comes up
to jack and he goes
um that's uh bentley's uh
hump pig and jack's
immediately like you know it was like
just a look in his faces but it got even
more hilarious from that because
within the scene jack was given the job
to give the dog
the command to hump and the dog had
performance anxiety and was not in a
humping mood
and so jack is on set going and and the
key word was boner
and so jack's on set with this toy going
boner boner boner
boner
it was also the commitment that jack had
because jack was trying to figure out
what was going to get the dog
to hump the pig so he was trying
different voices so he would be like
boner boner
[Music]
talk about a ringtone that would have
been
a hell of a ringtone yeah we're gonna
get
we've got to get onto cryptke to release
that footage after a round
it's good it's got to make the uh the
the blooper reel for sure
that alone will be a blooper reel
[Music]
uh
you